nz was denkst du denn die nächsten drei
videos dort sehr herzlich willkommen zu
einer neuen video hier mitmacht
ja und wir machen heute wir machen heute
eine neue folge wir heute wieder eine
neue folge youtube mit ihrer liebe leute
dazu haben wir damit unsere
schiedsrichterin youtuber vorgeben
[Applaus]
neben meinen heutigen gegner und youtube
imitator der großmessen youtube
angeboten
okay das ist richtig das okay kannst du
mir so wenn ich mir wünsche so frauen
musik jahren jedem bei jedem bekannt
da die stimme steht jetzt erst mal mein
punkt machen wollte gibt ja nur zwei
feierlich voll informiert die britin
fand über und point das war ein alter
brauch dann stecken ich bin vor goalie
kommen jetzt nun das schneiden bei
polytec mit einem 3 1-erfolg und
imitation für nicht ratifiziert ist
[Gelächter]
du kannst eigentlich auch kein problem
den zuschauer sorgen der leute die
schiedsrichter dem motto punkte wert
gewonnen
denn die klubs 0 1 0 und wir machen
weiter mit dem zweiten youtube begrüßen
so eine späte folge mein auto wurde
zerkratzt junge priester so wie du bist
mein auto zu einem neuen liebe grüße
meine lieben freunde der firma hab ich
das doch sein land
geschlüpft und luca kampf wieder über 50
der sagt nicht dass mich denn was ihr
100 leistungen lag ihr angebot aber wer
die werte hoch kommen schlechte jahre
hatte chrysler überlegung entschieden
dass max dafür ein bekommen will ich nur
einen punkt damit liegt macht vor mir
mit einheit ein
[Musik]
julia julia damit es zwei zu eins zu
eins
[Musik]
jetzt gelten drei videos natürlich leute
bitten
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
ok dann gegen youtube
hey leute und guten morgen aus stockholm
ich bin heute hier um rennen zu fahren
selbstverständlich denn ich bin bei
professioneller rennfahrer und heutige
damit steht weinheim zu 22 und macht
gewinnt diese challenge vor der
schiedsrichterin vor mir markt
gratuliere
[Gelächter]